>> Laura: MR. SPEAKER, IT’S
ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON,
ESPECIALLY ON A NIGHT LIKE
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WHEN THEY WEREN’T ARGUING
WHO IS A BIGGER RACIST,
DEMOCRATS AT THE DEBATE TONIGHT
EXPLAINING WHY A SOCIALIST
SHOULDN’T BE THERE 2020 NOMINEE.
THEY WORRIED IT MIGHT LEAD TO
THIS.
>> IF YOU KEEP ON GOING, WE WILL
ELECT BERNIE.
BERNIE WILL LOSE TO
DONALD TRUMP.
AND DONALD TRUMP IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE AND SOME OF THE
STATEHOUSES WILL ALL GO READ.
IF WE CANNOT PULL THIS PARTY
TOGETHER, IF WE GO TO ONE OF
THOSE EXTREMES, WE TAKE A
TERRIBLE RISK OF REELECTING
DONALD TRUMP.
>> NOT ONLY IS THIS A WAY TO THE
DONALD TRUMP REELECTED, WE HAVE
A HOUSE TO WORRIED ABOUT.
WE HAVE A SENATE TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> Laura: AND THEY ARE ALL
RAISING THEIR HANDS ALL THE
TIME.
JOINING ME NOW, ARI FLEISCHER,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
CHRIS HAHN, FORMER AIDE TO
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER, HOST OF
THE AGGRESSIVE PROGRESSIVE
PODCAST.
YOUR BIG TAKE AWAY?
>> MY BIG TAKE AWAY FROM A
DEMOCRATIC POINT OF VIEW IS THAT
THEY SURVIVED.
NOBODY REALLY BOMBED THIS TIME.
BLOOMBERG BOMBS LAST TIME.
HE DIDN’T BOMB THIS TIME, SO HE
SAVED HIMSELF FOR THE FIGHT FOR
SUPER TUESDAY.
BIDEN DID DECENTLY, CAME ACROSS
A SOMEWHAT ARTICULATE AND WITH
ENERGY FROM A DIFFERENT
JOE BIDEN TONIGHT, WHICH IS HUGE
FOR HIM ON THE EVE OF
SOUTH CAROLINA.
BUT FACE IT, LAURA, IT’S A
THREE-WAY RACE.
BERNIE, BLOOMBERG, AND SANDERS.
>> Laura: DOESN’T IT SEEM,
AFTER NEW HAMPSHIRE BECAME
FAIRLY CLEAR WHO THE THREE WERE
GOING TO BE.
ARI IS RIGHT, IT’S DOWN TO THOSE
THREE.
’S TOM STEYER IS JUST BLATHERING
UP THERE.
KLOBUCHAR, SHE WAS VERY INTENT
ON WHAT SHE WAS SAYING, AND
BUTTIGIEG TRIED TO BE VERY
EARNEST, BUT NONE OF THOSE
GUYS -- NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE PRESIDENT, SO THEY
ARE JUST MAKING IT MORE LIKELY
THAT BERNIE BECOMES THE ULTIMATE
NOMINEE.
I’M GOING TO STICK TO WHAT I
SAID WEEKS AGO ON THIS, THAT IF
YOU DON’T DROP OUT AND COALESCE
BEHIND ONE ALTERNATIVE TO BERNIE
BERNIE, BERNIE IS GOING TO RUN
AWAY WITH IT AND WILL BE OVER BY
THE FIRST WEEK, SECOND WEEK
OF MARCH.
>> SO YEAH, I MEAN COME ON
BERNIE IS DEFINITELY IN THE
DRIVER’S SEAT.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
HOWEVER, WHAT BIDEN DID TONIGHT
MIGHT HELP HIM.
HE TOOK A NICE ATTACK ON STEYER
ON PRIVATE PRISON INVESTMENT,
AND IF HE CAN BACK THAT UP WITH
ADS, THAT COULD CUT INTO WHAT
STEYER HAS GONE TO HIM IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
LOOK AT THE POLLS IN
HE’S NOT REALLY LOSING GROUND
BECAUSE BERNIE IS GAINING
GROUND, HE LOST A LOT OF GROUND
TO STEYER, WHO HAS MADE AN
OVERWHELMING INVESTMENT IN
SOUTH CAROLINA AS HIS LAST STAND
STATE.
WHAT BIDEN DID TONIGHT WAS VERY
STRATEGIC.
HE HAD A GOOD DEBATE.
AND WHO KNOWS, MAYBE THIS COULD
HELP AND HAVE A BIGGER VERSION
OF VICTORY ON SATURDAY IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, AND PROPEL HIM
INTO SUPER TUESDAY IS A
REAL CONTENDER.
>> Laura: I JUST LOVE HOW
BIDEN DID EVERYTHING IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS BASICALLY ALL HIS IDEA
ALL NIGHT LONG.
I DID THIS, BARACK DID THIS.
I DON’T THINK BARACK PROBABLY
GIVE HIM MUCH EXCEPT GIRL SCOUT
PAINTING CEREMONIES OR
SOMETHING.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT HE GAVE BIDEN,
BUT HE TOOK CREDIT FOR ALL OF
IT.
I DO THINK THERE IS ONE WEAKNESS
THAT WAS EXHIBITED FROM
BERNIE SANDERS TONIGHT, AND THIS
IS HOW HE TRIPLED DOWN ON IT.
WATCH.
>> CUBA MADE PROGRESS ON
EDUCATION.
REALLY?
>> WHAT BARACK OBAMA SAID AS
THEY MADE RACE PROGRESS IN
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE.
THAT WAS BARACK OBAMA.
AMERICA HAS OVERTHROWN
GOVERNMENTS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
WHEN DICTATORSHIPS, WHETHER IT
IS THE CHINESE OR THE CUBANS DO
SOMETHING GOOD, YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
>> Laura: IF HAMAS BUILDS ALL
THOSE SCHOOLS, WHERE ELSE DOES
THIS HURT BERNIE BEYOND FLORIDA?
>> THREE TIMES TONIGHT BERNIE
WAS BOOED, AND HE CLEARLY GOT
ANGRY WITH IT AND STARTED
CHALLENGING THE AUDIENCE.
IN FACT, THIS IS THE SECRET
RECIPE FOR THE OTHER CANDIDATES.
THEY PUT PEOPLE, SUPPORTERS AND
THE AUDIENCE TO CHALLENGE
SANDERS COME WHEN HE MAKES
STATEMENTS LIKE THAT, AND IT
RATTLES HIM.
YOU NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
THE OTHER KEEPER SANDERS AS HE
HAS TO COMMENT SOME OF THESE
STATES, SUPER TUESDAY STATES,
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS CAN
VOTE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
THEY ARE OPEN.
GOING TO HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING ANYONE WHO IS IN FAR
LEFT.
THEY ARE GOING BE SURPRISED IN
SOME OF THESE GOALS, WHERE I
THINK BLOOMBERG WILL WIN SOME
SUPER TUESDAY STATES, AND I
AGREE WITH ARI.
TONIGHT, MIKE BLOOMBERG DID MUCH
BETTER THAN HE DID THE LAST
TIME.
THE FIRST DEBATE, THEY BEAT THE
CRAP OUT OF HIM, BUT HE SURVIVED
THAT IT ENDED STRONGLY.
>> Laura: SAYING HE IMPRINT
FROM THE FIRST DEBATE.
[LAUGHS]
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE COMPARISON
IS.
YEAH, I WOULD HOPE SO.
MY GOODNESS.
IT WAS PATHETIC, THE FIRST
DEBATE.
HE ACTUALLY STOOD UP AND SPOKE
AND DEFENDED HIS RECORD IN
NEW YORK AND THE ALL OF THAT,
TALKING ABOUT HOW HE HAD TOO
MANY FAT PEOPLE COME HE
BASICALLY SAID THAT AGAIN
TONIGHT.
I DON’T THINK THE COUNTRY IS
CLAMORING FOR BLOOMBERG.
I DON’T SEE THE BLOOMBERG THING.
GOING TO STICK TO WHAT I KEEP
SAYING, IT IS BERNIE UNLESS
SOMETHING WEIRD HAPPENS.
GO AHEAD, CHRIS.
>> YOU KNOW, LAURA, POLICY IS
ABOUT EXPECTATIONS, AND HE HAD
VERY LOW EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS
DEBATE.
HE CLEARLY CLEARED THAT BAR
TONIGHT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS THE LAST DEBATE BEFORE
SUPER TUESDAY.
AS FOR BIDEN TAKING CREDIT,
WE’VE ALL WORKED FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY ARE TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
EVERYTHING.
WHETHER THEY DID IT OR NOT.
>> Laura: I GOT TO GET ARI ON
THIS.
ARI SAID BIDEN DID A GOOD JOB.
ARI IS SUCH A NICE PERSON.
I THINK WE HAVE ALL FELT BAD FOR
BIDEN OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE SAID HE WAS
RUNNING FOR SENATE.
BUT HE ALSO SAID THIS TONIGHT
WHICH RAISED SOME EYEBROWS.
WATCH.
>> 150 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
KILLED SINCE 2007, WHEN BERNIE
VOTED TO EXEMPT THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS FROM LIABILITY.
MORE THAN ALL THE WARS,
INCLUDING VIETNAM OKLAHOMA FROM
THAT POINT ON.
CARNAGE ON OUR STREETS.
>> Laura: 300,000, MOSTLY
SUICIDES WITH GUNS, THAT’S A BIG
HALF OF THE COUNTRY.
>> I’M NOT GOING OUT OF THE
STUDIO, THERE IS CARNAGE ON THE
STREETS.
I’M AFRAID.
>> Laura: AT SOME POINT,
DOESN’T HIS FAMILY SAY, JOE, YOU
HAD AN INCREDIBLE CAREER.
>> THAT MOMENT PASSED.
WE HAD THAT CHANCE, AND HE
DECIDED TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT’S JUST A BLOOPER.
EVERY POLITICIAN MAKES A
NUMBER’S MISTAKE, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BIDEN’S ISSUE IS THAT HAS BEEN
HIS WHOLE PERSONA THE ENTIRE
CAMPAIGN UNTIL TONIGHT.
AND ON THE EVE OF SOUTH CAROLINA
WHEN HE NEEDS THE WIN TO STAY IN
THE RACE, I THINK HE SAVED HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> I THINK SO, TOO.
>> HE DOES A GOOD RACE IN SOUTH
CAROLINA, HE LIVES TO
SUPER TUESDAY.
>> Laura: FRANK, THERE WAS A
MOMENT WHEN BERNIE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND HOW IT
WORKS FOR JUST A SMALL SLIVER OF
PEOPLE.
WATCH.
>> THE ECONOMY IS DOING REALLY
GREAT FOR PEOPLE LIKE
MR. BLOOMBERG AND OTHER
BILLIONAIRES.
BUT THE ORDINARY AMERICAN,
THINGS ARE NOT SO GOOD.
LAST YEAR, REAL WAGE INCREASES
FOR THE AVERAGE WORKER WERE LESS
THAN 1%.
HALF OF OUR PEOPLE ARE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
THAT IS NOT AN ECONOMY THAT IS
WORKING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: FRANK, DOES THAT
WORK?
THE ECONOMY IS NOT WORKING?
>> THERE IS A BETTER QUESTION
THAN THAT, AND IT IS A QUESTION,
ARE YOU BETTER OFF TODAY WHEN
YOU WERE FOUR YEARS AGO?
61% OF AMERICANS, AN ALL-TIME
HIGH, SAY YES, THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKING THAT QUESTION SINCE 1980,
AND IT’S NEVER BEEN HIGHER THAN
THAT.
WHAT BERNIE SANDERS DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN NOT ONLY IS BETTER OFF
TODAY THAN THEY WERE FOUR YEARS
AGO, BUT THEY ARE EXPECTING THE
ECONOMY AND THEIR OWN SITUATION
TO IMPROVE.
HE IS MAKING A BIG MISTAKE, AND
REALLY, THE ONLY WINNER
TONIGHT -- AND YOU KNOW I HAVE
BEEN OCCASIONALLY CRITICAL --
THE WINNER TONIGHT IS
DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAW IS
CHAOS.
THEY WERE TEARING EACH OTHER
APART.
THEY CANNOT CONTROL EACH OTHER.
AND THE PUBLIC DOES NOT WANT
THAT.
II AM ONLY A DEMOCRAT, BUT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC DOES NOT WANT
THAT.
>> Laura: I WISH WE HAD TIME
TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE MODERATORS
DID, BECAUSE I WAS AN
INTERESTING APPROACH.
>> OH, THEY WERE HORRIBLE.
>> Laura: NOTHING PERSONAL,
IT’S PROBABLY HARD TO DO THAT.
I’VE NOT DONE THAT, EXCEPT WITH
YOU GUYS COME AND YOU GUYS --
YOU FOLLOW THE RULES PRETTY WELL
WELL.
WHEN PEOPLE DON’T STOP TALKING,
IT IS A DIFFICULT SITUATION.
POOR OLD BIDEN KEPT SAYING
NOBODY RESPECTS ME.
WE KEPT SAYING NOBODY RESPECTS A
NICE GENTLEMAN.
>> THEY DON’T KNOW MIKE ALSO
COULD NEVER ASK BIDEN ABOUT
GETTING ARRESTED IN SOUTH AFRICA
I MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY.
>> ATTACK, ATTACK, ATTACK.
>> Laura: THEY ARE FOR POT
LEGALIZATION, WE KNOW THAT.